hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey fresh out of the
shower we're gonna talk about the movie
Overlord sweeping the box office based
on the true story of soldiers who went
into Nazi territory and found out there
were zombies there stole the plans for
the Death Star it was crazy and this is
a much-needed movie alright so the
reason we decided to do this review
because you know a lot of people we knew
weren't gonna go check this out watch
our review if no one's really even
watching the movie what's going on I was
doing it well you see over in our
patreon
we do weekly q and A's TV show reactions
for many of shows let's plug ourselves
now shall we attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood as well as supernatural
Gotham Riverdale he does music video
coverage and one of our top reward tiers
is whatever video you request we must
definitely cover and today comes from
Lance door all the way from Canada Lance
has been one of our top patients for a
while and there's even been a couple of
months where you know he pledged for the
amount work that gets him a video
request video and Astra won so I figured
let's go out of our way for him and
let's see if anyone watches this video
on to our review officially we did like
a 1 trailer reaction for this many
months ago and I remember thinking like
this looks like a lot of fun this looks
fun looks like a really expensive
b-movie of the you know there was plenty
of those movies of Jean like the Nazis
were creating zombies and stuff it's a
total sci-fi mishmash can yeah come to
find out go watch this movie and
everyone's like it's really good there's
the weird thing I was hearing is it
seemed to be such a big surprise by how
it's actually a good movie and I'm like
oh it's probably like a lot of fun
probably does a really good job at what
it what it sets out to do in case you
guys could tell we shot this review by a
window hence the Jesus like about 10
minutes and in this movie I realize oh
wow
this is like a real film this isn't just
some schlocky campy b-movie it has its
b-movie aesthetic it's actually a film
and it's a it's a good one too I really
enjoyed it John what do you think yeah I
had a really good time too I mean I feel
like to me this is a b-movie for sure
that just has a lot better inclinations
and a lot more on its
mine than most b-movies do and I think
that's kind of the sweet spot this movie
hits because I wanted to make a movie
like this for a long time I want to make
sort of a sci-fi world war 2 monster
movie and I thought they realized it
really well they made some smart choices
along the way the cast is all good and
you know - a couple of things I had a
great time when I say b-movie I mean
it's more than that because you think
when you see the trailer that you're
really just walking into some really fun
possibly zombie flick it's actually a
really tense film I found there to be a
lot of suspense and while it has like
its horror moments a lot of the way the
horror moments are executed are kind of
generic there's some you know really
unique stuff there as well what really
surprised me was how tense from
beginning to end this film actually was
it pretty much plays out the way the
trailer lays out how the film will
unfold and the first half of this movie
and most of it actually is a world war 2
movie it surprised me about it was I
thought it was gonna be like alright act
1 world war 2 movie and then we're gonna
get into like zombie fun but really it's
kind of subdued indeed I don't even want
to call it zombie it's more like
infection or experimental thingy
yeah it's essentially just really
twisted Nazi experiments I mean yeah
I've heard of Josef Mengele take that as
a jumping-off point you know I mean the
movie itself yeah just thrives off this
really immediate energy cuz your plot
yeah situation and you're just kind of
watching as plans get made and things go
wrong until the very end yeah and I like
the way that in a subtle way they really
do kind of utilize the war aspect for
more than just a backdrop I mean it is
the that's what I thought it would just
be yeah you go in thinking like oh this
is just gonna be fun cuz you know ads on
bees and stuff world war ii it takes its
premise seriously enough that it is as
visceral as an actual war movie and it
takes the backdrop of d-day which is a
very significant event in the war and
uses its own weird little context to
like add to that and a historical yeah
it's kind of well I agree with you it's
like even though it's not like being a
horror movie all the time it has this
mood in this tone I'm just ominous 'no
sand really intense and media see
because so many of these sequences are
captured in one long shot as voice
usually our hero boys they might joke
on a depo yeah who's really good in this
and he's so often on his own just like
hiding his way through completely
ridiculous scenarios that you're just
with him for I'm a big fan of movies and
know how to capture movie from a certain
characters perspective and majority of
this film and say like 99% of it got 99
problems but it's captured from the
perspective of voices character and that
was the other surprising element to me
there's some damn good character work in
this movie you got some really solid
performances you got wide Russell is
Ford who's the main supporting character
who is like the leader of these troops
on this specific mission because well
together they lose most of their group
or the move even begins because they
have a mission to basically take out a
tower and this tower just happens to be
located on top of a secret lab where
they got experiments going on that's
literally the main storyline and the B
story is the experimental stuff which
involves into becoming one of the main
stories yeah but they really treat that
as the secondary tale I don't read it as
a mystery it's not really filled with a
bunch I'm just gonna use the word
zombies even though there could be an
argument about what the hell is to make
this review efficient think of a
Resident Evil movie and the way Resident
Evil movies have like zombie has been
also weird bio creatures and they're all
kind of together being able he means the
video game he doesn't mean the Resident
Evil don't misconstrue that the zombies
in this film it's kind of subdued in the
way they are presented like when there's
zombie moments or some freaking awesome
moment there's one moment specifically
that I don't want to give away they
taint at it in the trailer but when it
occurs the whole crowd what whoa it's a
really effective moment her moments and
funny enough it stars Wyatt Russell and
his performance Connor mines we have
some Kurt Russell movies I've seen
before they're elements that seems
straight out of films like the thing
today really their Diaries shouting or
like sounds exactly like Kurt Russell
his voice it sounds 100% like him this
film honors this psychological element
of these characters the zombie factor in
this film is restrained in a certain way
there it doesn't really explode into the
all-out zombie may have that you
probably expect this film to go cuz the
film has a B CinemaScore a higher Rotten
Tomatoes score than that
in terms of critics I think and I could
see why kinda has a B CinemaScore and
because of the fact that I think when
you see the trailer you're walking in
thinking you're gonna get fun zombie
mayhem film but what you really get is a
cleverly written tense World War 2
thriller with some zombie stuff in it
yeah that is subtly teased for the most
part and then eventually you get some
cool [ __ ] I mean the very first horror
scenario you're pitted with in the movie
is just human based is yes them in the
plane as the plane is being destroyed
and how scary it is just to be a soldier
on any mission at all and I love that
yeah it really lets you live in those
shoes yeah before throwing in the
islands I think it ramps up its sci-fi
elements in really gradual way yeah
which helps to make this just more of a
film than you expected so I imagine
maybe audiences might be taken aback
that it's not just balls to the wall
yeah there was that element of me that
was thinking a little bit more zombie
mayhem but really most of the violence
comes from killing Nazis it doesn't
really come from killing these zombie
creatures yeah there's a nasty
circumstances that make this whole thing
possible basically yeah you know you get
some really good performances from all
the soldiers all around you get a really
cool female lead in there you said it
might be her first movie Matilda yeah
yeah yeah she plays Chloe
in the movie I mean it does have those
this one element in the film that I find
a trope that is really frustrating the
character is someone who is you know
sexually assaulted and like even in this
movie I'm like it makes sense for the
time where they're at simultaneous I'm
like do it really really well and ick
for me honestly yeah and in a movie that
seems like it went out of its way to
kind of meet up with the conventions of
the now because it's like your main cast
is pretty diverse your main character is
black yeah you know and so in a movie
that seems like it's inclined to make
slightly better choices yeah when the
assault there's no actual rape in this
movie but when the assault is flirted
with I was kind of like oh this is kind
of a 1 element to this movie that I
really didn't need and I think that you
know you had to go to to make us hate a
certain character base yeah because you
got it you do get a good villain in this
movie that I thought they built up
pretty
well you get some good violence in here
I really love the cinematography to this
because haunting images because it still
feels like a horror movie from beginning
to end even when there isn't the zombie
stuff happening because like the first
half of this movie words primarily just
world war two stuff they shoot it like a
horror movie which I thought was it's
kind of weird to say it's cool when
that's a real thing that occurs and
there's still Wars going on yeah that
whole sequence is a nightmare yeah it
doesn't have to be they shoot they don't
shoot it's like shot like a war movie
but it's lit like a horror movie yeah
and I also really loved the music in
there they did such a good job I thought
with having certain music moments where
it sounds like a heartbeat but it's
really music that I had to check myself
guys that sound design or is that music
it's kind of a combination of both and I
think the one thing I was a disagreement
or maybe I just didn't notice I loved
the sound design in this movie I thought
I had we saw I saw it on IMAX at a
different IMAX in you saw that and I
adored the sound design in this film
there's one of my favorite elements to
it on a technical scale and you had some
criticisms about that I mean I thought
the score was great going back for a sec
I mean I love the way that they combined
both classic like brass elements yet
with more synthesized elements it all
felt really natural the sound design
itself I thought was great I mean just
the general noises they had going the
big issue for me ADR I thought the ADR
kind of I don't know if I was just in an
off mood and I got really distracted by
it or what but especially Wyatt
Russell's performance kind of got marred
by the ADR in the first act especially
for me so that when some scenes came up
later and it sounded like the Thai logs
actually in the room I had a lot easier
time with interesting yeah there were
just times where it's been combined with
the way the editing is especially in the
first act of the movie it just was
distracting to me for some reason
regardless these are really nitpicks
compared to the overall film I thought
this was wonderfully executed it was a
really tense thrill ride and I actually
like how they kind of held back on going
all zombie mayhem and they told a story
first that it had this element in there
to support that main story and it's
contained - yeah this is a mostly one
location it's got kind of a paranoid
almost thing asked by
the thing too is there are a lot of
different vibes this movie puts out that
you could touch two other movies and
stuff and the main thing from this is I
I hope it achieves some modicum of
success because I'm glad that somebody
funded a movie like this yeah you know
it's an original idea it's high concept
for sure but it's satisfying in a way
that's also like you said an actual
movie so it's not just resting on oh hey
remember grindhouse stuff we're gonna do
that again for two hours yeah it rises
above that for sure and it has some
great performances in here I highly
recommend this movie yeah I do I like
the trailer but then when I would catch
the trailers in a few days I'd be like
[Laughter]
watching wow this is so much better than
the trailer so yeah I highly recommend
it land store thank you so much buddy I
know we let you down with especially my
personal opinion on Bohemian Rhapsody
not liking it you loving it I felt like
I really broke your heart on that one
you almost some pledge from the patron
page sorry about that
I had fun at all sincerity I appreciate
you asking us to go check this out
because I had a great time and I really
I really didn't pleasantly surprised by
this film alright guys well thanks for
watching what did you think of overlord
have you not even seen it that's a
question subscribe to the react nation
click that notification bell hey check
us on patreon we got TV show reactions
Q&A as music video coverage love to have
you become a page photo check today